ich verneige in demut mein haupt vor dem
thüringer wähler
die thüringer haben heute die wende 2.0
gewählt wir haben sich von hass und
hetze nicht beeindrucken lassen
noch niemals in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik ist eine einzelne partei
und eine einzelne person so deformiert
worden wie wir liebe freunde und
trotzdem haben die thüringer dieses
ergebnis möglich gemacht
ein ergebnis das ein klares nein sagt zu
unserer erstarrten parteiendemokratie
ein ergebnis das ja sagt zu einer neuen
lebendigen demokratie und das ist unser
auftrag liebe freunde wir wollen eine
neue vitale demokratie in thüringen und
in deutschland wir haben als fdp haben
als afd in thüringen unter ergebnis mehr
als 100 prozent gesteigert das gab es
noch niemals im freistaat thüringen bei
den nächsten berg die absolute mehrheit
holen
der mief und der muss werden jetzt
abgeräumt werden liebe freunde wir
werden uns unser land jetzt weiter
zurück holen
das alte und morsche zerfällt vor
unseren augen das ist gut
liebe freunde in ost geht die sonne auf
folge werden die sonne jetzt halt über
ganz deutschland scheinen lassen wir
haben den osten blau gemacht und in
wenigen jahren werden wir eine
gesamtdeutsche volkspartei seien auf
diesem weg den wir gemeinsam gehen
werden
[Applaus]
ich habe danke zu sagen danke euch ein
ihr habt gekämpft bis zum umfallen
wir hatten hunderte wahlkampfhelfer in
thüringen die hier bis zum äußersten
wirklich alles gegeben haben wir haben
eine solche solidarität aus der ganzen
bundestag dr fahren das macht mich
glücklich und stolz und was ich hier an
gemeinschaftsgefühl erlebt habe das soll
der geist sein die in unsere neue
volkspartei in den nächsten jahren mit
sich trägt liebe freunde wir werden als
einheit bestehen bleiben diese einheit
ist mit den ost wahl noch einmal
gestärkt worden und wir werden in dieser
einheit noch geschichte schreiben der
russe deutschland
[Applaus]
ich danke euch allen ich bin sprachlos
fast schon und ich übergebe jetzt an
meinen freund und bundesvorsitzenden dr
alexander gauland und verabschiede mich
erst mal ich muss jetzt darüber in den
landtag
ich sage aber ich wir haben zusammen
gekämpft wir haben zusammen gesiegt und
jetzt ist es zeit zusammen zu feiern
genießt den abend führt an dass ihr
gekommen sagt lina braake liebe
thüringer parteifreunde
ihr habt einen tollen wahlkampf gemacht
und ja ich wiederhole es gegen hess
gegen hass und hetze im grunde genommen
allen deutlich gezeigt dass ist die
zukünftige volkspartei und liebe freunde
lasst mich auf zwei ergebnisse weil ich
sonst wirke nur wiederholen müsste weil
er alles richtig gemacht und jetzt auch
richtig gesagt hat lass mich auf zwei
ergebnisse eingehen dass die grünen hier
nur fünf prozent haben
diese partei ruiniert deutschland in
thüringen ab wird es deutlich
ausgesprochen
diese leute gehören in keinem parlament
und liebe freunde lasst mich noch ein
nachdenkliches wort sagen auch die cdu
muss sich überlegen ob sie künftig mit
linken und grünen und sozialdemokraten
regieren will oder mit der einzigen
bürgerlichen volkspartei liegen kraft
nämlich die afc und und die funktionäre
der cdu müssen sich überlegen ob sie auf
dauer auf ihre basis hören oder ob sie
den weg ins politische aus gehen denn
die cdu wird wie die spd als volkspartei
untergehen wenn sie diesen weg
weitergeht dann werden wir tatsächlich
bei 50 prozent landen und das hat sich
dann die cdu selbst zuzuschreiben liebe
freunde schließlich dem dank von new
yorker an